[Music]
now when it comes to the all-time greats
a few names probably come to mind Jordan
Gretzky the babe
who was a guy but maybe none are more
revered or have been more mortalized
than Muhammad Ali we know it said
earlier
foreign
[Music]
the photo taken from this fight by John
Rooney is arguably the most famous
sports photograph of all time Muhammad
Ali is one of those sports figures who
well not even just he transcends the
World of Sports he left a legacy
permanently etched into really American
culture at Large
but what if the Legacy that you know or
that you think you know is wrong so go
with me here for a second some of you
are going to be upset by the first half
of this presentation and then some of
you are going to be upset by the second
half so depending in which group you
find yourself I ask you to either fast
forward or rewind to the portion that
you find acceptable as this is usually
how we process complex historical
figures in order to make them more
palatable to our modern Echo chamber
sensibilities just do that
[Music]
Lee was the Ali you know he was known as
Cassius Clay then in 1964 Cassius Clay
ditched his slave name and joined the
Nation of Islam now please note the
Nation of Islam is important here it's
not the same as Islam and not
representative of all Muslims we'll come
back to that later so Ali converted
actually after he was handed a newspaper
cartoon outside of a skating rink in
Louisville Kentucky the cartoon
Illustrated how white slave owners
brutally beat their slaves while
insisting that they pray to Jesus the
message Christianity was the religion of
the oppressive white establishment I I
like that cartoon Ali wrote it did
something to me and it made sense now
after his conversion clay changed his
name to Muhammad Ali under the advice of
Elijah Muhammad the leader of the Nation
of Islam why do you insist on being
called Muhammad Ali now that's the name
given to me by my leading teacher The
Honorable Elijah Muhammad that's my
original name that's a black man named
Cassius Clay was my slave name I'm no
longer a Slave
what does it mean Muhammad means worthy
of all praises and Ali means most high
do you intend to fight under Batman yes
sir I want to be called by that name I
write autographs is that name I want to
be known all over the world as that name
especially throughout Asian Africa
because that's the names of our people
over home now here's the thing about
Elijah Muhammad don't let the name fool
you as he was in fact intensely racist
he believes that white people were
actually created by Jacob a black
scientist Elijah even believes that
Allah had allowed the devilish race to
hold power for six thousand years but
that the 20th century was the time for
Less satanic black people to assert
themselves Elijah unsurprisingly was a
huge proponent of racial segregation
would you disagree that it is the
ambition and the goal of most Negroes in
this country to become Americans
in every meaning of that word to
participate in our society to be
responsible legitimate honest citizens
is yet the goal of the overwhelming
number of negroes in this country
uh it may be
at that goals
Mr cup because that they don't even know
as I just said
uh
that this is the time that they should
be going for some
and uh lack of knowledge of the time
their lack of knowledge of self
the American so-called negro especially
the leading crash
do not actually know themselves little
known fact about Elijah also proponent
of tiny hats and during this period in
his life of course Muhammad Ali also
was an advocate of segregation
you got bad all of a sudden right
overnight it was a good boy when I was
hollering I am the greatest I cannot be
beat I am pretty I'm the king he he I
was a good boy but when I said I'm
Muslim My Relations this long what's
wrong with that you have 600 million
Muslims on Earth and Muslim only mean
one who submits entirely to the will of
God our law and Islam only means peace
entire submission to God
and during this time Muhammad Ali's
views on interracial marriage were
not great
as he noted in a 1975 Playboy interview
while requesting that John Wayne kindly
hold his beer
a black man should be killed if he's
messing with a white woman and not just
white men black men too we will kill you
and the brothers who don't kill you will
get their behinds whipped and probably
kill themselves if they let it happen
and don't do nothing about it tell it to
the president he ain't gonna do nothing
about it tell it to the FBI we'll kill
anybody who tries to mess around with
our women ain't nobody gonna bother them
and when questioned by the interviewer
about a Muslim woman wanting to date
outside of the Faith Ali said then she
dies kill her too at one point Martin
Luther King Jr even called Ali a quote
champion of segregation now here's the
interesting part this is precisely the
period in Ali's life for which he has
received
the most praise and veneration in the
media because it's these same beliefs
that played a huge role in Ali's refusal
to serve during the Vietnam war in 1967.
at the induction ceremony Ali refused to
step forward when his name was called
a Navy Lieutenant explained the penalty
should he be found guilty of refusing
induction
a ten thousand dollar fine and up to
five years in prison
given another chance to step forward
Ali refused again
ladies and gentlemen
Mr Muhammad Ali has just refused to be
inducted into the United States armed
forces and back then protesting the war
was like catnip for media as opposed to
today we're advocating War uh over there
in Russia and Ukraine so here Ali was
actually sentenced to and wrongfully
sentenced to five years in prison he had
a ten thousand dollar fine and a
three-year ban from boxing then his case
was appealed and eventually overturned
by the United States Supreme Court in
1971 and it's at this time in his life
that Ali was venerated into a civil
rights Progressive anti-war folk hero a
reputation which the media desperately
wants to highlight and cling to to this
day now here's something you may have
forgotten Muhammad Ali wasn't just an
impressionable young racist in his
personal life though he was he even
profited a lot from using blatant racism
against other black opponents and no no
I'm not talking about the kind of racism
that Sparks outrage today in the form of
unprovable dog whistles Ali's Prejudice
was more of a
[Music]
a racist bull horn
blaring Atop A bigotry percussion sets
supported by prejudicial Woodwinds in a
particular Target of Ali's rage and
racist vitriol was one of his most
notorious Rivals Joe Frazier
[Music]
foreign
Joe Frazier is an interesting character
he actually had a really hard upbringing
in poverty in the Deep South whereas Ali
came from a middle class background and
Frazier actually gave Ali a thousand
dollars when he was bankrupt during the
Vietnam war protest to cover his
expenses the two men fought three times
with Ali beating Frazier twice and if
you watch on Mud Club we'll get to some
opinions on that Ali also demonized
Frazier routinely in blatantly racist
terminology things like 98 of my people
are for me they identify with my
struggle if I win they win if I lose
they lose anybody black who thinks
Frazier can whoop me is an Uncle Tom Ali
also called Frazier himself and Uncle
Tom and lobbied the black community to
view Frasier as a race Trader in 1974
this all came to a head with Ali and
Frazier getting into an on-air scuffle
on the Wide World of Sports with a
famous host Howard Cosell
just when you were in the hospital now
you're wrong
I went to hospital for 10 minutes she
went for a month now be quiet at that
point Holly said you're ignorant sad it
was a difference
and Joe stood up ripped off his
microphone
what do you mean I'm angry
sit down Joe why you think of me sit
down Joe sit down
here
quick Joe
before the October 1975 Thrilla in the
Manila which was the final meeting
between the two boxers Ali even compared
Joe Frazier to a gorilla bringing out
props I'm gonna give him a real whooping
and
a righteous I got a little gorilla here
this is his attention I keep him right
in my pocket everywhere I go back there
it says it will be a killer and a
thriller and a killer when I get the
gorilla in Manila the fight would come
to be remembered as one of the most
brutal in boxing history
[Applause]
I'm going to get up in the ring
Ron let me help you
[Applause]
I'm up in the ring here
and Muhammad Ali is pretty well defensed
and I'm going to try to get over at him
we're we're trying to get in here
to talk to Ali who has retained his
title and I think he needs a little air
because this has to have been one of the
most bruising Heavyweight Championships
of all time interesting aside here what
a lot of people don't know about this
fight is that Ali actually wanted to
throw in the towel while Frazier who was
basically blind at this point in one eye
and blinded in the other eye by Ali's
effective jab he was protesting against
it telling his Corner man that he would
never forgive him if he threw in the
towel at the same time Ali was demanding
that Dundee cut off his gloves here's
how ESPN reporter Ben Blackmore
described it in one corner sat Frazier
almost blind in both eyes pleading with
trainer Eddie fudges to not throw in the
towel in the other was Angelo Dundee
reaching for his own piece of cotton to
end Ali's misery in the face of what
Shirley qualified as human torture
futch was the man to get the referee's
attention ahead of Dundee retiring
Frazier just a handful of seconds too
early to unwittingly give Victory to Ali
Who as a wrecked shell of a human being
could barely acknowledge his Triumph
even after their athletic rivalry ended
rather than forgive and forget Joe
Frazier was so upset by Ali's
race-baiting and turning the black
community against him that he carried
that animosity with him to his grave
speaking in the 1990s at an event in
Philadelphia Frazier said of Ali who by
this time was already suffering
tragically from Parkinson's disease we
locked up three times he won two and I
won one but look at him now I think I
won all three even when Ali was tapped
to light the Olympic flame at the 1996
games in Atlanta Frazier said to a
columnist in the Philadelphia Inquirer
if I would have been on the platform
with him I would have thrown him into
the flame
Frazier also remarked in his 1996
autobiography truth is I'd like to
rumble with that sucker again beat him
up piece by piece and mail him back to
Jesus now people ask me if I feel bad
for him now that things aren't going so
well for him nope I don't fact is I
don't give a damn they want me to love
him but I'll open up the graveyard and
bury his ass when the Lord chooses to
take him so it could be argued that
Frazier was less forgiven forget than he
was remember forever and ruminate over
violent felonious Revenge fantasies
here's the thing Frazier was not an
outlier it was kind of Ali's calling
card Ali played up racial divides versus
a lot of opponents a George Foreman
being one of them during the famous
Rumble in the Jungle in Zaire in October
1974 before the fight Ali said regarding
Foreman who waved the U.S flag at the
1968 Mexico City Olympics which is a
whole story in its own right I'm going
to beat your Christian ass you why flag
waving also that famous chant in
Zaire Ali bumaye that translates to Ali
kill him here's the thing people make
mistakes people change Ali was no
exception after his return to the United
States a reporter asked Muhammad Ali
champ what did you think of Africa to
which Muhammad Ali responded
thank God my granddaddy got on the boat
[Music]
so Ali's Redemption began in early 1975
and by Redemption
I mean the part of this story and
majority of his life which those in
Legacy Media desperately attempt to
memory hole and want you to ignore it's
around this time he left the Nation of
Islam denounced the teachings of his
former peers in favor of the more
mainstream and peaceful Sunni Islam Ali
wrote in a 2004 biography the Nation of
Islam taught that white people were
devils I don't believe that now in fact
I never really believed that but when I
was young I had seen and heard so many
horrible stories about the white man
that this made me stop and listen Ali's
daughter in fact told PBS that her
father softened his heart later in his
life and expressed his views about what
they viewed as the one true religion the
religion of the heart one of my father's
favorite sayings was rivers lakes and
streams all have different names but
they all contain water
but do religions have different names
but they all contain truth
he always taught me that there's only
one true religion and that's the
religion of the heart he would say and
as long as you do right and you treat
people right you know I believe you're
going to heaven no matter what you call
your religion
here's a kicker that most of you don't
know at all Ali also became more
conservative throughout his life even
going so far as to endorse Ronald Reagan
now Ali had originally endorsed Jesse
Jackson which is kind of a flip so when
asked why he announced his support for
Reagan Ali told reporters he's keeping
God in schools and that's enough for
context this endorsement is after Ronald
Reagan rebuked Ali's desire to reinstate
his boxing license when he was still the
governor of California Back in 1970
saying forget it that draft Dodger will
never fight in my state now before you
say oh it's just the lesser of two evils
and their friendship isn't already
painfully clear here's Reagan and Ali
together at the White House during his
1983 re-election campaign
if the idea of Ali endorsing the
arguably whitest of the most modern
presidents surprises you how about ali
actively campaigning for possibly the
whitest human being who ever lived
because that's exactly what Ali did for
Oren hatch
a white a very white Mormon republican
from Utah and they maintained actually a
lifelong friendship Ali speaking on
Hatch said man he's one of the most
effective leaders in the U.S Senate
anytime he wants me to be there I'll be
there I think he's the greatest greatest
with a capital G I know some of you may
say that these two political actions
from Ali were outliers maybe there were
yet another phase based on individuals
he liked rather than being reflective of
his changed values but Ali was
remarkably consistent for the rest of
his life even up until 2015 when the
terror attacks that killed 130 people in
Paris Ali released a statement
condemning Islamic radicalism which in
and of itself may not be reflective of
what we're discussing here but stay with
me he said I am a Muslim and there is
nothing Islamic about killing innocent
people in Paris San Bernardino or
anywhere else in the world true Muslims
know that the ruthless violence of
so-called Islamic jihadists goes against
the very tenets of our religion now
again that would seem like something
that most could be on board with here's
the kicker the media headlines tried to
frame that quote as a jab aimed directly
at then candidate Donald Trump and his
islamophobia despite the fact that Ali
never mentioned his name this is from
the guardian Muhammad Ali defends
Muslims in response to Donald Trump's
ban plan from Vox one of Muhammad Ali's
final public statements refuted Donald
Trump's islamophobia from The Beacon of
Truth it is the Associated Press Ali
responds to Trump's call to ban Muslims
from entering the United States Donald
Trump however
never believed that it was directed
toward him saying no that wasn't about
me
now
now this is where the context matters
the easiest thing for Ali to do when
being given a layup from the progressive
media warping and speculating right the
easiest thing would have been to say
nothing instead the Ali family also made
it clear through one of their official
spokesman Bob Gunnell they went out of
their way
to clarify that the statement was in
fact not directed at Mr Trump but
exclusively at extremists and jihadists
again many of you probably don't know
this but this wouldn't come as a
surprise to anyone who knows that
President Trump and Muhammad Ali they
had a long-standing friendship including
Trump receiving not one but two awards
from Muhammad Ali during his lifetime
for charitable donations Donald Trump
also threw a birthday party for Muhammad
Ali in 1988 with invites being sent out
to over 500 guests in 1991 Trump left a
divorce negotiation with Ivana to speak
at an awards dinner for Ali in New
Jersey and then went back Ali also by
the way attended Donald Trump's wedding
to Melania back in 2005 and far from The
Young Nation of Islam disciple who
advocated the execution of race mixers
Traders Muhammad Ali became a dedicated
and consistent humanitarian and actual
peace Advocate helping people worldwide
to advance freedom justice and equality
Ali was the largest single black
contributor ever to United Negro College
Fund I can say the word because it's in
the name it's a racist acronym Ali
actually donated 50 cents of every
ticket for his close circuit television
title match against Chuck wepner to help
the drought-stricken Sahel region of
West Africa interesting aside here that
fight was being watched by Sylvester
Stallone and became the inspiration for
none other than rocky and putting the
politics of his younger days aside Ali
even helped stop a Vietnam veteran from
attempting suicide the hooded man
shouted I'm no good I'm going to jump
the Viet Cong are coming at me police a
psychologist and a minister had all but
given up trying to change the despondent
man's mind when Muhammad Ali who
happened to be nearby volunteered to
talk to him
the former heavyweight champion went to
a window and reportedly yelled I'm your
brother I want to help you recognizing
Ali the man finally opened the fire
escape door and Ellie approached him on
the ledge it was a very tense 20 minutes
several times it looked as though Ellie
was going to fail
then suddenly it was all over the man
Ali said later began to weep he was
taken to the psychiatric ward of a
Veterans Hospital the former champ
promised to visit him there later this
week so like I said certain portions of
this video will rub a lot of you the
wrong way I know that in other portions
will irritate an entire separate segment
but when it comes to Ali and his life's
transformation
it's the truth a truth that I find
heartening and more Americans would
benefit from knowing but the equally
disturbing truth is that many of you I'm
willing to guess most of you
probably are hearing a lot of this for
the first time because the truth as
inconvenient as it may be
has been obfuscated by our media and the
entertainment Industries lies and that
begs an important question why
does the mainstream media actively
ignore Ali's transformation from the
hateful and bigoted young man that the
Nation of Islam turned him into as
opposed to the compassionate
conservative leaning humanitarian he
came to be and if he's one of the most
iconic civil rights Sports Heroes to the
black community in American history
how does it benefit the black community
how does it benefit America at large to
ignore his Redemption could it be
because that very Redemption coincides
with a very inconvenient why could it be
that the reason and inspiration for
Ali's renouncement of his former racism
runs counter to the narrative that her
entertainment and media industrial
complex desperately want you to believe
is the reason that racism still exists
today in the first place whether it's
Ebenezer Scrooge the Apostle Paul hell
even Robert Byrd in a transformation
story in a Redemption Arc the why is as
important as the figure themselves so
why did Muhammad Ali change so
dramatically and why do most people not
know about it leave a comment talk about
it below I'm genuinely curious to hear
your opinions and if some of this is new
information now granted there is plenty
for which to critique
the man Muhammad Ali
and there's plenty that he did right
it's complicated like many historical
figures but
it is impossible to doubt Muhammad Ali
formerly Cassius Clays lasting impact on
America at Large
or his greatness
I have wrestled with an alligator out on
tussle with a whale out in handcuffed
lightning throw thunder in jail
that's bad only last week I murdered a
rock Angela Stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick man dude
fast fast
last night I cut the light off my
bedroom hit the switch was in the bed
before the room was dark incredible fast
incredible and you George Foreman all of
you Chumps are gonna bow when I whip him
all of you I know you got him I know you
got him picked but the man's in trouble
I'm gonna show you how great I am